welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were discussing everything we know so
far about the upcoming second season of
lock-and-key season one ended on a big
cliffhanger and it's left a lot of
things up in the air we're gonna be
discussing the best theories on what
could be coming down the line as well as
what happens in the graphic novels
storyline and more obviously that will
be heavy spoilers here so if you're
about to pick up the comic book or just
don't want to know what may happen in
the future then I highly suggest that
you turn off now make 'shy subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day
and without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown okay so though we don't have a
specific release date for locking key
just yet we do know that the second
season is currently in production when
speaking to GameSpot the weekend
executive producer Colin Q stated we're
writing season two even though it hasn't
been greenlit we're working in a room so
things are still kind of up in the air
it is good that they're writing it but
as of yet Netflix still haven't fully
confirmed it the first season currently
has a rating of 78 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes so across the board it seems
like people are enjoying it Netflix tend
to confirm 30 days after a show's
release whether it's going to be renewed
or cancelled but ratings do look
positive for the property
Netflix follow-up entries tend to
release between 12 to 14 months after
the initial season comes out so this
would put the future release in between
February and April if it is confirmed
I'm like chilling Adventures of Sabrina
part 4 which was in production before
the third season came out it is likely
that if the entry does go ahead it will
be more towards the back end of this
estimation as it still needs to be
written and filmed it was announced
today that the Radio Times will be
announcing the release date in March so
whilst we don't have a specific date it
won't be too long before we know for
definite as for the season itself the
first entry centered on the lock family
returning to their ancestral home and
discovering a big secret in the house
there were several magical keys that
granted special abilities and because of
this they were highly sought after the
youngest of the group Bodhi ended up
freeing a demon named dodge and
she or he depending on who they were at
the time became a big antagonist for the
family it was a great narrative and
season one ended on a massive
cliffhanger with it being revealed that
dodge had been masquerading as Gabe a
close friend of the locks they believed
that they'd successfully defeated dodge
but it turned out that they dumbed
Elian to the plain of length after being
tricked into believing that she was the
villain though I felt a series dragged
early on
due to its focus on the high school
elements rather than where the real meat
of the plot was by the end I was hooked
and desperate to see more though the
first season followed some notable
moments from volumes wanted for the
comic book run that doesn't mean that
the plot is set in stone going ahead the
graphic novel series is wrapped up
completely but the 37 issue run merely
inspired the events in the show rather
than cementing the way things will be
when speaking to The Hollywood Reporter
Meredith averell the show creator said
the world Joanne gate created is so rich
with so much potential for places to go
that I feel like we have many stories we
want to tell the stories we tell in
season one our launching points for many
of the stories that have yet to come
producer Cuse and reiterated that they'd
spent a lot of time working alongside
creator Joe Hill who'd given them some
ideas on what to do but he stated that
going ahead this season will be
diverting from the comics in some ways
with Collider they said that they viewed
the show as a sort of remix and we've
seen this work to great effect at
certain points during another big comic
book TV show The Walking Dead when
discussing what could happen going
forward they teased that things are not
ideal at the start of season two that's
how one should want it as a storyteller
Dodgers turned out to be even more
formidable than they could have imagined
but by the same token across the season
our kids have come to learn that they
are the new keepers of the keys and that
they have the responsibility that goes
with that both sides have stepped up
their game for what's going to happen in
season two so it looks like going ahead
we will be keeping a similar aesthetic
with a central location becoming a
mainstay once more but what happens in
the book and how could it draw from that
again full spoilers here for the graphic
novel arc but there are a couple of
things that I do think may come to
fruition so in the storyline after the
events early on that prick
much focused on the discovery of key
house and the return of Sam dodge and
his high school disguised as a student
this has been murdered in gabe and
similar to the version we saw play out
in the season he ends up befriended the
keepers of the keys he gains their trust
and similarly the group from 88 they
decide to divide them up with dodge
trying to recover the Omega key Dodge is
eventually discovered and with his cover
blown
he possesses Bodie as the young boy he
can finally walk about the house and
also get the keys because of this Dodge
manages to grab the Omega key and he
throws an after-prom party in the sea
caves where the Omega door is located
dodge opens this and releases several
demons
however Tyler and Kinsey managed to
force dodges soul back into the well and
because they believe that Bodie had died
from the possession they decide to
cremate him really sad ending but in the
epilogue the lochs fortune alpha key
that frees the spirit of Dodge from
Lucas at the well and they're also able
to resurrect Bodie which ends the comic
now before we get into my theories going
ahead I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of dr. sleep to
one random subscriber all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the updates
in the comment section below the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
February and the set will be shipped out
from the enter forgets the prize it's
the best of luck to everyone he takes
part okay so we know that two demons are
on the loose and that one is in Eden
actually have a pretty big theory that I
think Dodge may end up being killed at
the end of the second season and it will
be a big twist that brings the rivalry
between him and the locks to a close not
only would it shock fans will also
divert heavily from the source material
which the creators seem to be wanting to
do in the original work Ali never gets
sucked into the black door so clearly
they're looking to change things up from
the ending point onwards actually think
they brought a new demon in with the
form of Eden to set her up as the big
villain going ahead in the show the
group pretty much humiliated her at one
point and no doubt the anger within her
will have been enhanced further by the
demon that is now possessing her
I think Gabe will continue to integrate
with the camp and that he will actually
be an earth base
who as we know is still out in the world
there was a specific reason that the
show chose to show his spirit and I do
believe that this will pay off down the
line actually think that Sam will be
paying close attention to the family and
the keeper of the keys and this is where
he will discover gabe isn't who he says
he is
bori will likely use the ghost key once
more to travel to another form of
existence in order to learn more about
the keys from his ancestors and it's
during this time that i believe he will
come across sam and learn the truth it
is possible that with his soul out his
body that dodge could use this
opportunity to possess him but i don't
think that the series will show the
death of Bodie rather he will have to
fight back to get control of his body
and then he will reveal what's really
going on it is likely that the next
season will feature a whole host of new
keys as well and currently we've only
seen a fraction of those that exist in
the source material in the books there
were almost 40 so yeah there's a
plethora to choose from when it comes to
narrative devices that the series could
go the showrunners stated that they
don't know how many seasons they would
like to do yet but have stipulated by
the time they get to season 2 they will
have more of an idea where they want to
take it
q said we want to be sure that the
ending works for the TV series and we're
not just forcing ourselves into an
ending for endings sake we won the
ending to be something that really feels
like it's the right conclusion for our
story so it's likely they want to get
the established things out of the way by
the end of season 2 then perhaps journey
in their own direction I know the eden
thing is kind of that feel but it's just
something that stuck out to me when I
was thinking why she'd been introduced
and what they could possibly do with her
either way I'm really hyped for a second
season
and I can't wait to hear what plans the
showrunners have for it down the line
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on lock and key so comment
below and let me know like she subscribe
to the channel for videos like this
every day and if you want something else
to watch we've got a great breakdown of
the first season which is gonna be
linked at the end we talked about all
the ins and outs of the season and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and considers video topics and
breakdowns we massively appreciate it
and it goes a long way to helping videos
like this get
you only come chatters after the show in
the follow us at definition whitey I'll
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you